[Music]
this is luke krafka's passion
music and live performance the
professional cellist from brooklyn
often plays in concerts with a changing
cast of musicians
who are usually paid in cash and he says
mobile payment apps have made that task
a lot simpler paypal venmo cash up yep
there's no paper involved there's no
checks involved there's no waiting you
get paid
right away goes to your bank account
it's actually made it's made life a lot
easier
he also plays at weddings in october
2019
a new customer reached out to hire him
it was gearing up to be
a normal you know wedding and i had
reached out to my friends they were good
for the gig
the client told him he'd send him a
check roughly a thousand dollars for
krafka
and another 950 to pay for the client's
sound man who he asked krafka to then
pay
through a mobile payment app and i said
look if you send me the money
that's no problem that's fine mobile
payment apps allow users to pay
others immediately through bank accounts
or credit cards connected to the app
it's easy simply hit a few buttons on
the app on your phone
and your friend or contact gets the
money right away
usually a good thing but not always as
krafko was about to find
out he deposited the wedding client's
check for nineteen hundred
sixty dollars i checked you know the
following day
and the full amount was in my bank
account
then as requested he sent the client
sound man 950 dollars
through the payment app zell i believe
it was the following day
that check bounced
and when that happened then i
slowly started to put all of this
together
sure enough the people who supposedly
hired him stopped answering his calls
and he was out 950 dollars and i said
look i think i've been scammed
krafka and many others this report from
the u.s public interest research group
or perg looked at over 9 000
complaints to federal regulators about
digital wallets and payment apps
including paypal venmo cash app and zell
they found over 2 700 were filed between
january and april of this year
up over 300 percent from the same period
last year
with many losing money to scams or fraud
if it's a scammer it is not coming back
perks ed merzwinski says compounding the
problems
is that unlike with credit or even debit
cards app
transactions are instantaneous there are
no rules that protect you
very well at all when your money goes
out of your account and into somebody
else's account
especially if you initiated the
transaction and sent the money
a lesson krafka learned when he reached
out to his bank to get his money back
they told him there was nothing they
could do i was surprised that there was
no recourse and that
once it's done it's done and there's
nothing you
can do